inutile de dire à quel point nous sommes
flattés de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau tamouls coup c'est un grand
plaisir d'être ici je connais très peu
de français j'ai appris quelques mots au
sujet de la féminisation du monde alors
je connais quelques mots en français
pour le dire c'est très vrai dans cette
histoire de féminité sur ce que vous
savez par exemple que on peut
reconnaître les gens leur échapper
regardez le chapeau de calcul il ya cent
ans les hommes portaient ces chapeaux
qui qui était en fait rigide comme les
femmes ont commencé à prendre le pouvoir
il fallait que ces chapeaux ça me lis un
petit peu c'est donc les hommes ont
commencé à porter ses chats peu plus mou
et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il porte des
des casquettes de baseball à l'envers et
c'est ça la féminisation du monde en feu
dans la voix l'estimant serre vous êtes
d'accord avec eric zemmour le monde se
féminise de tout à fait raison c'est
fait tu mets difficile soutient alors là
ces gens là se faire dire être américain
l'appendice c'était bien il faut avoir
une vision xtra environnementale pour
pouvoir prouver vous avez raison là
dessus ça y est la haye mécontents unis
pour se donner raison
tom moi c'est le costume noir où c'est
le costume blanc vous avez dit davantage
d'apporter toujours le même costume
c'est que ça donne une idée aux
journalistes pour commencer leurs
papiers et une fois vous aviez fait une
très mauvaise interview mais le
journaliste avait été fasciné par votre
costume et vous avez compris que ce
n'était pas la peine d'avoir une
personnalité
il suffisait d'avoir un costume blanc
effectivement et c'est tout ce que j'ai
ce soir
cela étant il ya une chose comme et qui
est très nouveau en effet très fin
quelque chose qui viennent des états
unis justement et que je vais vous
présenter ce soir
regardez c'est ce qu'on appelle une
cravate j'ai pas jean pas au camp nou au
kilo de raisin regardez audibien vous
cravate on français pour cet objet est
alors je peux vous dire ou pour vous
pouvez retrouver si ça vous intéresse
vous êtes le dernier à porter une
cravate
je croyais que je croyais être le
premier jeu ça fait tellement longtemps
que j'ai vu des cravates je n'ai pas vu
en france on quelqu'un depuis mon
arrivée alors tom moult vous êtes à 75
ans le dandy terrible de la littérature
américaine
on vous doit le gauchisme de park avenue
le mot pain l'eeetop des héros acid test
le bûcher des vanités et un homme un
vrai
[Applaudissements]
énorme écrira un en france je suis très
impressionné quand je savais qu'il était
là j'avais presque le trac espèce
d'inquiétude
j'ai acheté plein de livres pour les
faire dédicacer pour les garder dans la
bibliothèque mois écouter pour moi c'est
un mythe ça vous ne savez plus grands
écrivains argent et je dois dire je fais
partie de ces journalistes qui ont été
élevés au lait de tom wolf
quand il avait besoin de ce livre qui a
été un choc pour moi en voyant dans ces
articles dans rolling stones kiss eux
restent absolument mythique et il avait
écrit ce livre vous souvenez qui est un
recueil d'articles gauchisme le
gauchiste de parcage radical chez sorti
chez gallimard en 1972 vous soyez encore
moi ça a changé ma vie je suis je
surpris comme plein de journalistes
français vous avez fait des petits
partout en france pourtant wolf enfin
voilà et et c est après évidemment je ne
parle pas du bûcher des vanités de tous
ses livres merveilleux enfin j'ai pas
encore lu le dernier mais à chaque fois
pour moi ton vol c'est joli tout je me
précipite sur le vous ne vous étiez
passé ces reproches que je peux vous
faire quand même
c'est vrai c'est que vous êtes un peu
circonspect quand même alors peut-être
que vous écrivez beaucoup plus que vous
publiez
mais ça manquait il faut attendre
parfois cinq ans paroles parfois
davantage encore ses très longs mois ces
éléments extraordinaires c'est le il
renoue avec le modèle balzacien français
en fait c'est à dire que de moi ce que
j'adore danser romance et qui mélange
tout la société les politiques les
avocats les lélés les noirs des ghettos
noirs américains pressing merveilleuse
copa réseau ce qu'il faut faire c'est de
prendre ma retraite je crois que la
seule chose honorable que je puisse de
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
alors comme vous publié aujourd'hui chez
robert laffont un livre qui s'appelle
mois charlotte simons
alors si c'est une autobiographie le
titre est mal choisi il sait mieux
partis que paris c'est moi c'est vrai
mais avant d'avenir livre je voudrais
justement parler de la méthode
vous avez commencé par le journalisme
vous avez même inventé dans les années
60 le nouveau journalisme qui consiste
pour un journaliste a utilisé des
techniques littéraires pour faire un
journalisme qui se lit comme un roman et
c'est lors de ses débuts dans le
journalisme que vous avez appris à aller
enquêter sur le terrain je vais déclarer
les écrivains doivent sortir de leur
coquille pour aller chercher le matériau
de leurs livres c'est ce qu'ont fait
dickens balzac zola parcourir la société
comme un reporter son porter de jugement
et en retranscrivant ce convoi bref
commencé par une enquête mais me semble
vraiment que aujourd'hui l'imagination
de l'être humain n'est pas n'arrive pas
disons à la hauteur de ce qu'il va
trouver sur le terrain la réalité
dépasse de loin la fiction en mille ans
vous ne trouverez jamais dans votre
imagination autant de choses que ce qui
se passe dans le monde ce que font les
gens de ce que pensent les gens
1 je donne un exemple est ce qu'on
connaît paris s'il tonne ici et là alors
son cas m'intéresse qu'un romancier
aurait pu imaginer une histoire dans
lequel linéaire belle héritière est
retrouvé sur un cas cette vidéo porno et
ensuite le reste du roman parlerait de
ses parents sourds
de chantage que ces changements
n'importe qui peut imaginer ce genre
d'histoires pas très intéressantes ou
bien une autre histoire ou bien une
belle héritière son talent reçoit 10
millions $ pour passer à la télé mais
aucun écrivain a eu l'idée de dire voilà
cette femme qui a gagné tout cet argent
parce qu'elle a fait justement cette
cassette porno on n'y pense pas ce genre
de choses dépassent l'imagination du
romancier je crois que il faut vraiment
c'est des choses incroyables le monde
est vraiment très étrange
la réalité dépasse de loin la fiction à
l'image nationaux qu'il faut aller sur
le terrain voir la réalité
contrairement aux autres écrivains vous
ne partez pas d'un thème ou d'un ou deux
personnages avant de trouver le milieu
dans lequel vous allez les maîtres mais
vous partez du milieu à yuzhou i had you
are est généralement le processus est
inverse par rapport à d'autres romans
civ disons que moi ce qui m'intéresse
d'abord trouver un cadre contexte le
milieu mais dans le sens le contexte
général
alors ce sera par exemple wall street ou
bien les tribunaux comme dans mon
premier roman ou bien lors les
promoteurs immobiliers j'écris un roman
là dessus ou encore je ne sais pas par
exemple justement un campus
universitaire et puis ensuite c'est les
personnages attendent des personnages
entrent sur ce décor et les pressions
sociales jouent un rôle tellement
important et même les décisions
fondamentales sont prises à cause des
pressions sociales bon j'ai pas déflorer
l'histoire mais quand même quand
justement parlons de déflorer charlotte
perd sa virginité je sais pas si les
gens savent encore ce que c'est qu'une
virginité mais enfin elle prend une
décision sociale à ce moment là si j'ai
laissé ce garçon a des citoyens est tout
nu à ce moment là mais je l'empêchent
d'aller plus loin et bien on va me
traiter de
d'allumeuse et alors ces gens de
décision est une décision non pas
exceptionnel décision affective et une
décision presque sociale politique à la
limite et chante la vie est souvent basé
là dessus c'est des cons on réagit aux
pressions sociales
alors pour votre dernier roman donc moi
charlotte simons vous est parti d'une
enquête approfondie sur les campus des
universités américaines et vous avez
découvert d'abord que le sexe l'alcool
ont remplacé la culture et l'esprit
c'est en tout cas ce que j'ai pu
remarquer aux etats-unis peut-être à
l'exception de la suède les états unis
sur le seul pays où les étudiants de
premier cycle vivent sur un campus
c'est à dire que dans des dortoirs mixte
ce qu'on appelle les collègues alors
vous avez des jeunes dominent plein de
testostérone avec des jeunes créatures
du deal à côté des vous les mettez
ensemble dans les mêmes dortoir à votre
avis qu'est ce qui va se passer avant
tout cas alors vous décrivez une
jeunesse sans morale ni discipline ou
scrupules et dans cette jeunesse sur ce
campus comme un chimiste qui mettrait
une goutte d'acide dans une éprouvette
vous plongez charlotte simons qui est
une étudiante sérieuse innocente coincé
intello vous la mettez là dedans et vous
regardez justement ce qui se passe oui
je voulais un personnage comme elle est
un personnage qui est plein d'avenir une
fille intelligente mais qu' un petit peu
ils ont un but d' elle-même parce
qu'elle sait qu'elle a quand même
beaucoup de talent et elle pense par
dominer le monde grâce à son intellect
et puis alors elle se retrouve dans un
monde où elle est soumise à toutes
sortes de pressions sociales sexuelles
alors je peux pas prendre sept minutes
mais y est ce qu'on appelle la technique
de la séduction en sept minutes
c'est une vieille technique qu'est ce
qui se passe vous avez des groupes de
garçons et de filles c'est pas qu'ils
ont un regard pour ce nom c'est des
groupes qui sont mises en place
dans une espèce de contexte où va
rencontrer quelqu'un dont vous avez des
garçons à côté des filles de l'autre
alors un gars on remarque une fille
qu'il trouve attirante s'approche et se
présente et il va essayer quelque chose
de très très cool du genre je parie que
tu en as marre qu'on me prenne pour
britney spears tout le temps ou alors ou
pour paris s'il tonne
ce genre de compliment vraiment très
content hélas si elle marche dans la
combine
alors il s'assied à côté d'elle alors il
va l'effleuré sur le braz la seule
partie du corps que l'on peut toucher
sauf si les noms sert la mannequin
tanneron tout ça en l'espace de 2
minutes 30
et puis ensuite question suivante on
danse
ok ils se mettent sur la piste de danse
et à la danse consiste à quoi elle
consiste à rejoindre les parties ils ont
public vu bienne pardon et puis ensuite
il s'agit de les frotter l'une contre
l'autre pendant à peu près trois minutes
donc on a maintenant il ya cinq minutes
30 qui se sont écoulées et pied au bout
de sept ans l'un demande à l'autre est
ce que il y a quelqu'un qui te ramène
chez toi en fait c'est un langage codé
pour dire on va dans ta chambre dans la
mienne
alors là on arrive aux sept minutes donc
tout est en quelque sorte times est
chronométré c'était quelque chose de
complètement nouveau que je connaissais
absolument
alors au début effectivement charlotte
simone se croit capable de résister à la
médiocrité et la vulgarité ambiante à la
pression du groupe et puis finalement
elle finira par abdiquer par se
conformer aux autres et votre théorie en
fait c'est que tout est statut c'est la
position sociale c'est le standing qui
mène le monde en fait
pensez par exemple au choix d'un
partenaire de vie bon c'est tout est
déterminé socialement quelquefois il y
aura quelqu'un qui va dire bon allez il
va épouser une femme qui à 50 ans de
plus que lui bon ça arrive assez
rarement ça peut exister ou alors vous
aurez je ne sais pas quelqu'un qui tombe
amoureux d'un animal bon là encore c'est
relativement peu fréquent généralement
c'est quand même
le statut social qui détermine ce genre
de choix même ses choix qui sont censés
être passionnel
[Musique]
monsieur
à
alors il ya un problème quand même c'est
que george bush a déclaré que charlotte
simons était un des meilleurs livres
qu'ils avaient lu si je vais vous dire
quelque chose grâce à ça tu as des
grands chapitres de mon existence
le new york times a appelé ou et
journalisme a dit george bush adore
votre livre il le recommande à tout le
monde
à votre avis pourquoi est ce que c'est
parce que se livrent leur appel ces
jours quand il était étudiant il buvait
beaucoup dansé ces fraternités jeudi je
sais pas je ne sais pas pourquoi est ce
livre lève c'est peut-être la qualité
absolument époustouflante de l'écriture
c'est peut-être tout simplement sa passe
est une épée alors la journaliste me dit
mais est-ce que vous avez voté pour
bouger répondu lui je n'apprends rien de
nouveau mais enfin en disant que j'avais
voté pour bush bon y'a quoi 62 millions
288 1482 personnes qui ont fait la même
chose donc c'était pas si exceptionnel
que sable enfin bon lorsque j'entre dans
une salle avec d'autres écrivains les
gens me regarde d'un drôle d'air c'est
comme si j'avais levé la main pour dire
à propos je vais vous dire je suis un
pédophile ce qu'on dit à quelqu'un qui
vous dit quelque chose comme ça c'est un
petit peu gênant dix ans donc j'ai été
un petit peu ostracisé ou en tout cas on
estimait que j'étais un personnage un
peu suspect à cause de la façon dont
j'avais voté mais bon cela étant jeune
homme ne commençait politique et on n'a
droit qu'à un seul vote ans aux états
unis on peut pas voter plusieurs mais
vous n'échapperez pas tamoul à une
interview bush au logis
alors ce sont des citations exactes de
george bush sur lesquels je vous
demandait de réagir par exemple quand il
dit je crois que nous sommes d'accord
le passé c'est fini tous d'accord en
effet offert il ya l'expression on dit
bon il faut aller de l'avant d'être
souvent je crois que c'était ça qu'il
veut dire c'est à dire que le passé est
le passé
je crois que c'était simplement ça qu'il
voulait dire sinon la correction
relativement normal alors quand il dit
c'est évidemment un budget il ya plein
de numéro 2 dans ce jeu c'est tout ce
qu'on peut dire sur le budget c'est
comme nombre il a déclaré aussi de plus
en plus de nos importations viennent de
l'étranger
[Rires]
une telle vérité s'il a dit je sais ce
que je crois je continuerai à exprimer
ce que je crois est ce que je crois je
crois que c'est ce que je crois et bien
c'est cité ses sources et tout ça par
rapport à ça quand même
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'écrivains qui
ont eu l'occasion de s'entretenir avec
le président de questions littéraires
moi j'ai eu ce privilège
une petite conversation avec lui et
curieusement il parle beaucoup mieux de
littérature que par exemple le rédacteur
de la publication à collecter la plus
prestigieuse des états unis qui
s'appelle le new york review of books
c'est plus que le viseur
alors il je continue je vous demande pas
de réagir à chaque fois mais c'est pour
le plaisir de les entendre
il a dit nous prenons les bonnes
décisions afin de mettre fin à la
solution ça me fascine zazie il a dit
cet argent est le vôtre vous avez payé
pour la voir j'aime pièce
il a dit je crois que vous m'avez mal si
vous estimez très joli ça assez poétique
il a dit les gens s'attendent à ce que
nous échouions notre mission est de
dépasser leurs attentes
[Rires]
bien souvent c'est quand même le dé les
journalistes quoi inventer tout ça non
la troisième priorité est de donner la
première des priorité à l'enseignement
est alors la dernière quand même si nous
ne réussissons pas nous courons le
risque d'échouer
[Rires]
ouache en maxime a séduit chez robert
laffont et les messieurs
les
tous
thank you merci merci d'avoir été avec
vous je voulais sortir avec les monty
cause il était connu pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu